salut à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
titre en images de cette édition
à 24 heures du choc de la 15e journée de
Pro B de tennis de table entrée en cours
et Mayenne l'entraîneur et l'encourtois
fonctionnier nous dressera les ambitions
de son équipe avant le sprint finale les
Cougars de montigny-en-bassball peaufine
eux les réglages avant la reprise de la
division 2 le joueur historique du club
Alexandre Couton a pris la succession
d'Arnaud faux coaching pour débuter un
nouveau cycle pour sa septième édition
les cotrails de Paris partait de la base
de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines plus de
1500 trailers ont dévalé les 80 km de
l'épreuve toujours aussi respectueuse de
l'environnement et puis évidemment en
fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end mais tout d'abord place au
tennis de table
je le disais dans les titres à 24 heures
du choc de Pro B que tout le monde
attend en tennis de table entrée en
cours et Mayenne un choc qui va sûrement
asseoir un peu plus la suprématie de
l'une ou de l'autre équipe l'entraîneur
et l'encourtois Frank Saunier nous fait
l'amitié de passer sur le site Sport
bonsoir à vous Franck merci d'être là
tout d'abord une première question après
10 journées parce que vous vous avez
disputé 10 journées il y a des petits
décalages des exemples dans cette poule
de Pro B et l'encours est deuxième
j'imagine que l'entraîneur que vous êtes
est très satisfait de ce premier bilan
c'était l'objectif prioritaire du club
cette saison donc on a quand même
travaillé à l'intersaison pour pouvoir
accéder à la division proie là on est
deuxième avec quand même deux matchs de
retard par rapport à Mayenne donc on est
très très bien placé et bon même
mathématiquement on peut plus être joint
donc on peut déjà dire qu'on est
accédant à la division supérieure c'est
à dire la plus haute division en France
quoi qui est la proie féminine voilà un
exploit historique pour le club puisque
c'est la première écoutez ça sera la
première montée dans la proie en tant
que tel en fait
il y a quelques années et là oui
effectivement on est c'est une première
pour le club voilà donc non on est on
est déjà très content du parcours on
n'est jamais même si le championnat est
encore terminé il se terminera début
juin on est on est vraiment satisfait
déjà de ce qui se passe je vous propose
de jeter un petit coup d'oeil au
classement justement pour qu'on voit ça
concrètement vous êtes voilà deuxième
avec 10 journées jouées 29 points un
petit point derrière Mayenne mais qui a
deux matchs d'avance autant dire que
vous avez votre destin en main pour
finir premier de cette poule déjà on va
essayer de faire quelque chose de bien
il y a un demain soir
le but c'est d'aller essayer de gagner
sur sur le club de Mayenne
je pense sans prétention que si on
arrive à battre Mayenne demain soir on
peut aller chercher la petite cerise sur
le gâteau c'est à dire d'aller chercher
le type de shampoing de France quoi
voilà donc l'objectif il est là c'est
d'essayer de battre Mayenne chez nous on
a été les battre au match aller bon il
jouait pas avec leur équipe au grand
complet mais bon on a su saisir notre
chance donc demain on s'attend c'est un
beau match c'est un beau match j'espère
qu'il viendront au complet ça nous
donnera une petite idée un petit peu de
ce qui va nous attendre la saison
prochaine parce que c'est une belle
équipe normalement sur le papier et oui
oui on aimerait bien gagner quand même
demain soir par rapport à ce bilan donc
10 journées je vais je le disais quasi
parfait en fin de compte ce bilan un
neuf victoire un match nul c'est la
petite imperfection ce match nul
bizarrement match nul sur une équipe qui
est beaucoup moins bien classé avec la
queue que nous avec un contexte un petit
peu particulier c'est à dire qu'on est
parti jouer à Grenoble avec une joueuse
qui pouvait quasiment pas marcher le
matin et que c'était bloqué le dos dans
la nuit
et euh qui cette fois 7h du matin chez
l'ostéopathe qui nous l'a bien remis en
place quand même il a fait un super
boulot et puis une joueuse qui avait la
grippe qui a joué avec 42 fièvre donc
c'était pas simple mais ce qui était
plutôt intéressant c'est de les voir
jouer aussi un peu dans la douleur elle
voulait pas perdre c'est vraiment pas
envie de perdre donc Audrey déjà bien
entamé la rencontre la petite a bien
entamé la rencontre en ayant chercher
une bonne victoire et puis après elles
ont fait le boulot elles ont été
chercher le match nul donc bon on est
reparti justement ce refus de la défaite
un petit peu parce que vous êtes du coup
la seule équipe encore invaincu dans
cette poule mais quand même on avait 9
victoires sur 9 matchs le 10e on fait
match nul on n'a pas été jusqu'à 18h
pour l'instant mais là j'ai une équipe
avec
elles aiment pas trop perdre on a quand
même les joueuses qui commencent
notamment notre leader qui s'appelle Eva
dorova qui qui est la plus âgée enfin je
l'ai dit que c'est notre leader mais
enfin quand on a quand même deux très
très bonnes joueuses qui jouent à ce
niveau là mais c'est une par
l'ancienneté surtout par son expérience
du niveau international et je peux vous
dire que quand elle a perdu un match à
Grenoble c'était vraiment la soupe à la
grimace et même le lendemain matin au
petit déjeuner c'était pas agréable
justement j'allais y venir il va au
bureau va change peut-être radicalement
le visage de votre équipe cette saison
par son expérience sa maturité sa
connaissance aussi du haut niveau
puisqu'elle a joué en Pro A par le passé
c'est quand même une fille qui a été
championne d'Europe aussi qui a été dans
les 100 meilleurs joueuses du monde même
numéro 49 mondial à un moment donné de
sa carrière qui a participé aux Jeux
Olympiques qui a fait 16e de finale aux
Jeux Olympiques donc c'est ça reste une
très bonne joueuse et puis c'est sûr que
nous ça nous a apporté on va dire de la
sécurité et puis une bonne connaissance
de ce milieu là donc elle rassure ça
c'est clair qu'elle rassure justement
dans votre équipe il y a un savoureux
mélange entre l'expérience d'Eva et puis
la jeunesse la foule si j'ose dire dos
de réserve la jeune Adré arrive qui a 15
ans on a toutes les générations
actuellement là sur le club c'est assez
incroyable ce qui est plutôt bien aussi
c'est un bon mélange comme vous dites
on a Audrey arrive qu'à 15 ans qui
arrive là cette année aussi sur le club
et qui est en train de faire un parcours
assez remarquable parce que on vient
d'apprendre il y a même pas trois
semaines un mois qu'elle était qualifiée
avec l'équipe de France seniors pour
aller représenter la France au Japon
pour les championnats du monde à Tokyo
donc ça c'est quand même une chouette
expérience pour elle
je pense elle a du potentiel elle a une
forte personnalité et ce qui est très
bien c'est que elle essaye d'apprendre
tout le temps au quotidien quoi elle
adore être au quotidien avec les
joueuses les retrouver pour les matchs
par équipe puisqu'elle est elle
s'entraîne à l'INSEP actuellement donc
elle devient que sur des petites
périodes sur le club et il y a cette
cerise sur le gâteau aussi puisque il y
a quelques semaines aussi elle s'est
qualifiée pour les Jeux Olympiques de la
Jeunesse et ça c'est quand même c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable parce que
elle partait pas dans les meilleurs
joueuses européennes pour cette calife
faut savoir que la qualification aux JO
elle est très dure même en jeune c'est
quasiment le même parcours que pour un
seigneur en tennis de table donc elle
avait trois jours pour se qualifier
c'est qualifier dès le deuxième jour et
même pour la Fédération c'était un
événement important parce qu'ils ont
qualifié aussi un garçon sur ces Jeux
Olympiques de la Jeunesse la Nanjing en
Chine donc au mois d'août et c'était un
objectif assez important pour la
Fédération donc ils ont réussi leur coup
et puis audrey a vraiment elle a fait un
excellent parcours avec que des perfs et
pour vous situer un peu son parcours
c'est que au niveau mondial elle était
cassée classée dans les 500 meilleurs
joueuses mondiales donc 470 au départ et
là au jour d'aujourd'hui elle est 183e
joueuse mondiale un sacré bon donc c'est
beaucoup parce qu'après l'enchaîné des
sorties internationales ou avec la
confiance qu'elle est engrangé sur cette
qualification elle a fait des perfs
incroyables sur les open sur les open
internationaux et ben là
pour sa première année de Junior a fait
une super saison pour revenir sur ce
match de demain on va essayer de faire
peut-être monter un peu la pression
justement il y a de la pression les
filles pour demain pour se dire faut
qu'on soit et qu'on finisse première de
cette poule oui elles ont ça dans la
tête ça c'est sûr qu'on s'est mis ça à
partir du moment où on savait qu'on
allait grimper à l'étage au dessus on
s'est dit ben maintenant faut aller
chercher le petit susu sucre comme on
dit c'est le titre
donc elles ont ouais je crois que tout
elles ont quand même envie déjà de
gagner ce match demain soir parce que ça
veut dire quelque chose pour elle quand
même même si on a été gagné à l'aller
assez facilement mais elles ont vraiment
envie de s'imposer et même jusqu'à la
fin de la saison quoi donc ouais le
titre ça devient maintenant l'objectif
aussi maintenant de l'équipe très bien
rendez-vous donc ce mardi au Palais des
Sports et en cours pour suivre ce choc
de la 15e journée de prouver entrer en
cours évidemment et Mayenne merci
beaucoup Franck d'être passé sur le site
sport et puis on suivra évidemment ce
possible titre en fin de saison à 19h30
on passe tout de suite au baseball
à 5 jours de la reprise du championnat
de Division 2 évidemment on suit les
Cougars de Montigny et la présidente
emblématique du club est présente sur le
site Sport bonsoir Annie Couton bonsoir
évidemment il y a eu du changement à
l'intersaison les Cougars de Montigny
peaufiner un petit peu les derniers
réglages avant la reprise de la saison
et il y a un nouvel entraîneur que vous
connaissez bien tout à fait en l'espèce
de votre fils évidemment Alexandre
Couton il a pris la relève d'Arnaud faux
au coaching pour débuter un nouveau
cycle
il comptait faire une pause et
s'éloigner des terrains mais finalement
à 32 ans Alexandre coton découvre le
costume d'entraîneur joueur des
couillards depuis 1998 le short stop
deuxième base a accepté fin janvier de
prendre la succession d'Arnaud faux pour
rendre service au club mais pas question
de faire du cumul de mandat le fait de
revenir en tant que coach je veux
vraiment faire les choses bien et je
sais que c'est pas facile de pouvoir
faire les deux en même temps donc je
préfère d'abord me concentrer sur le
coaching et puis on a largement de quoi
faire dans l'équipe pour sa première
saison sur un bon senior Alex Couton
pourra se reposer sur le retour
d'anciens joueurs comme Sébastien
Duchaussoy ou encore Wesley Coop man le
nouvel entraîneur ENI Montin compte bien
utiliser la génération dorée des juniors
qui ont frôlé le titre de champion de
France la saison passée des renforts qui
pourraient permettre au cougar de faire
mieux qu'en 2013 les inhymontins avaient
terminé en tête de la phase régulière
mais ils étaient passés à côté de leur
demi-finale dans un premier temps les
playoffs et puis après
faudra prendre match par match on n'a
pas d'objectif on va dire à court terme
de monter pour l'instant c'est après on
finit premier bah le club verra on veut
rejouer en élite mais il faut qu'on ait
l'équipe pour pouvoir faire bonne figure
dans le dans la première division
élément de réponse lors de la première
journée sur le terrain du premier René
avant de passer à la saison la première
question qui me vient évidemment à Nice
c'est que c'est quand même une affaire
de famille
je regrette un peu qu'Alexandre a décidé
d'arrêter de jouer parce que je pense
qu'il avait encore du potentiel pour
faire des paires performances bon c'est
son choix il avait d'ailleurs fait une
excellente saison tout à fait donc on
comptait sur lui encore pour sur cette
saison mais bon il a préféré cocher donc
nous ça nous a beaucoup par rangé
lorsque nous avons appris Carnos en
aller de pouvoir nous reposer sur
quelqu'un qui connaît bien le club et
qui connaît bien les joueurs et qui
connaît bien les jeunes donc bon mais là
c'est l'entraîneur rendêtement fils
c'est important de le signaler vous
démarrez du coup un nouveau cycle un
petit peu même s'il y avait déjà cette
formation c'est un Montigny la formation
des jeunes est très importante mais
Alexandre me l'a confié il veut essayer
de les introniser encore plus dans
l'équipe première cette année tout à
fait d'autant plus que cette année le
championnat régional Junior est un peu
compliqué car nous sommes pratiquement
le seul club à avoir un fort vivier de
Junior de France le il va y avoir bien
entendu un championnat junior mais qui
se résume à trois équipes et pour le
moment les deux premiers matchs qui
auraient déjà dû être joué n'ont pas pu
être joué donc pour nous il est
important quand même que les joueurs
jeunes et du temps de jeu donc ils vont
être intégrés dans les dans les trois
éclips seniors pour pouvoir déjà
s'affronter à un niveau un peu plus haut
et sur cette équipe première menée par
Alexandre Couton vous êtes d'accord avec
votre fils l'objectif minimum c'est les
playoffs minimum oui pour moi l'objectif
pour moi l'objectif serait au moins la
demi-finale
faire au moins que aussi bien que l'an
passé voire mieux voir mieux des
ambitions des rêves ou des souhaits de
titres pour cette fin de saison je pense
que oui on a toujours des souhaits de
titres pour une fin de saison parce que
c'est quand même un bonus pour le club
c'est un bonheur pour les joueurs quand
même c'est
l'aboutissement du travail accompli
toute l'année puis comme on intègre des
juniors c'est aussi peut-être
l'aboutissement de la formation de tous
ces jeunes et puis par rapport à ce
titre aussi qui c'est un titre que vous
enfin après lequel en tout cas vous
courrez depuis quelques années ça serait
bien de le décrocher enfin tout à fait
le dernier titre de champion de France
c'était en 2008 donc c'est vrai que le
précédent était en 1998 donc j'espère
que nous ne fonderons pas 2018 vous
parliez justement des jeunes les juniors
c'est vrai que la saison de baseball en
France elle est un petit peu décalée par
rapport aux autres saisons des autres
sports pour les jeunes c'est plus dur
d'attendre comme ça début avril pour
pouvoir jouer avec les seniors c'est
plus compliqué à gérer ou pas non pas
vraiment parce que comme tous les ans
nous avons quand même de jeunes joueurs
enfin des jeunes gens qui n'ont jamais
joué au baseball qui sont venus
s'inscrire au forum des associations
tous les ans nous en avons et donc pour
eux ça permet quand même de d'apprendre
les les bases du baseball et puis ils
ont quand même joué avant début avril
puisque des débuts mars nous avons
entamé notre habituel tournoi des
American School donc début mars nous
avons joué contre l'American School de
Paris et l'American School de Waterloo
et le week-end prochain nous allons
encore jouer contre l'American School de
Paris et je n'ai pas encore la
connaissance de quelle american school
d'Europe va venir jouer avec nous donc
c'est quand même pour eux intéressant
aussi de d'affronter des jeunes gens qui
qui ont baigné dans le baseball dès leur
naissance justement là vous parliez de
ce manque d'équipe en championnat
régional comment vous l'expliquez il y a
pas assez de clubs assez intéressants et
structuré pour pouvoir avoir un
championnat correct dans la région alors
c'est une politique de certains clubs
qui je préfère utiliser leur joueur pour
jouer en seniors
nous n'avons pas tout à fait cette
politique nous voulons que chacun reste
à son état bon alors effectivement cette
année nous allons faire comme les autres
nous allons faire jouer nos juniors en
seniors mais non pas parce que ça
n'avons vraiment besoin et tout
simplement pour leur donner du temps de
jeu et puis c'est vrai que les juniors
c'est quand même un peu difficile ils
veulent s'affranchir de leurs parents
mais dans la majorité des clubs
franciliens voir d'Île-de-France les
terrasses sont très éloignées des
centres-villes donc ils ont un peu de
mal à aller vers les terrains puisqu'ils
ne sont pas forcément motorisés et
qu'ils ne veulent plus de leurs parents
alors qu'à Montigny nous avons la chance
d'avoir un terrain qui est en plein
centre-ville et c'est ça qui nous
apporte beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs
puisque nous avons de la visibilité bien
sûr et puis c'est ces jeunes il faut le
rappeler c'est quand même une génération
doréens quand même les les Yuki Antoine
il y a beaucoup de talents donc c'est
presque normal on a envie de dire qu'il
puisse intégrer un jour l'équipe
première bah oui tout à tout à fait de
tout temps il y a eu quelques jeunes qui
ont intégré avant l'âge l'équipe
première parce qu'ils avaient le
potentiel qui leur permettait et puis ça
leur permet de se former aussi pour
pouvoir après prétendre à jouer
peut-être à plus haut niveau et voir au
niveau de l'équipe de France par rapport
aux jeunes encore on va rester un petit
peu sur les jeunes les 15 jus on sait
que les moins de 15 ans vous êtes plutôt
bien loti aussi cette saison il va y
avoir encore sûrement des quêtes de
titres et puis d'autres trophées ah bah
cette année nous avons comme tous les
ans l'ambition de jouer le titre le
titre de champion de France puisque nous
sommes les champions de France sortant
nous avons à l'intention de remettre
notre titre en jeu bon les règles du
championnat ont un peu changé puisque
maintenant il y aura des tours
qualificatifs que c'est un peu différent
des autres années mais en Île-de-France
il y a trois clubs qui renforce
forcément sur les finales des
championnats de France et nous pensons
être dans ces trois clubs et puis pour
les 15unes nous avons comme l'an passé
l'ambition d'aller et nous allons aller
d'ailleurs ce fameux tournoi Little
League en Italie qui va permettre de
sortir une équipe européenne puisque
Montigny sera encore l'équipe qui
représentera la France pour pouvoir
partir aux États-Unis au mois d'août
donc l'an dernier nous avions fait un
bon parcours alors que c'était la
première fois que nous allions dans ce
type de tournoi nous sommes arrivés 4e
bon évidemment que seul le premier pas
mais cette année avec l'expérience que
nous avons eu l'an passé nous comptons
aller surtout que nous allons récupérer
pour pour ce tournoi Mélissa Mahieu et
Fred Walter qui sont partis au CREPS de
Toulouse donc et qui ont bien
l'intention de revenir jouer avec nous
on le sait à Montigny il y a toujours
des belles générations chez les jeunes
vos équipes de jeunes fonctionnent très
très bien le palier est vraiment trop
important pour pouvoir maintenir ses
résultats en seniors c'est encore
compliqué à passer ce saut
oui c'est assez compliqué puis de toute
façon souvent certains de nos jeunes
nous quittent puisque beaucoup vont
faire des études partent faire leurs
études et ne jouent plus au baseball et
puis certains sont attirés par les
sirènes de grands clubs qui jouent en
élite et penche enfin division 1 comme
maintenant et je les comprends donc
peut-être que si nous faisons
suffisamment de travail avec les jeunes
joueurs et resteront avec nous pour que
nous puissions nous aussi à notre tour
avoir un club avoir une équipe en
division une très bien en tout cas on
pourra déjà en observer quelques uns de
ces juniors avec les équipes seniors et
pour l'équipe première match ce samedi
donc face aux promus rennais et c'est à
l'extérieur arabe arrête voilà merci
beaucoup merci de sport à très bientôt
pour ça septième édition les co-trail
c'est de la course à pied les
cotterelles de Paris partaient une
nouvelle fois de la base de loisirs de
50 ans en Yvelines plus de 1500 trailers
ont dévalé les 80 km de l'épreuve
toujours aussi respectueuse de
l'environnement
après 5h40 de course l'expérimenter
manuel Go s'impose sur les cauterelles
de Paris 2014 version 80 km reste
toujours aussi beau varié plaisant
difficile aussi je le répéterai jamais
assez mais
c'est une course magnifique mais je peux
vous dire que ça essore vraiment dur dur
6h plus tôt les 1579 participants se
préparent dans le sas de départ un
effort d'une extrême intensité si
certains découvrent le parcours parisien
d'autres trailers habitués ne
louperaient pour rien au monde les
cotrails avec des très très jolies
portions de monter de descendre c'est
essentiellement fait de relance et la
soirée sur le gâteau c'est l'arrivée
la plupart sont très exclusivement pour
cette course depuis plusieurs mois par
dose d'une centaine de kilomètres par
semaine sur une distance aussi longue le
trailer doit surtout gérer son
alimentation mais aucun papier par terre
sur le parcours à chacun sa touche écolo
c'est surtout ça les cotrails s'il y a
un truc qui m'agace c'est les papiers
par terre les petites dosettes par terre
moi ça non ça il faut pas ouais ouais
vraiment ça c'est un truc super
important en montagne c'est pareil ouais
ouais on ramasse tout c'est
indissociable indissociable donc un bon
trailer sans son petit sac de
récupération de sachets plastiques ça
n'existe pas au bout donc de 5h40 de
foulées Emmanuel go a remporté en
solitaire ce 7e écho trail de Paris sous
la Tour Eiffel
allez on passe à l'ensemble des
résultats du weekend
en football 18e journée de promotion
d'honneur et un week-end lourd de
conséquences vous allez voir au niveau
comptable pour Guyancourt pendant que
trap s'inclinait face à sures 2 à 0 le
SG est allé chercher un bon match nul
sur la pelouse du deuxième Tremblay un
partout mais vous allez le voir malgré
ce bon résultat l'aiguille en courtois
sont désormais lanterne rouge de leurs
poules C de promotion d'honneur avec 28
points égalité avec le PEC et
Saint-Cloud mais avec un golave rage
défavorable et plus inquiétant encore
les joueurs de jute talmorroz n'ont plus
gagné depuis le 23 février dernier la
lutte pour le maintien va se faire
jusqu'à la dernière journée toujours en
football Division d'Honneur cette
fois-ci pour le compte de la 17e journée
Versailles 7e recevait le 9e
Blanc-Mesnil au stade Montbauron ce
dimanche dans un match plutôt équilibré
les occasions ce sont succédé de part et
d'autre mais les Versaillais ne
parviennent pas à concrétiser leur temps
fort ils seront même sauvés par leur
gardien de reprise les deux équipes se
séparent finalement sur un score nul et
vierge 0 à 0 un sixième match nul de la
saison qui satisfait tout de même
l'entraîneur Versailles et David Giguet
dans son contenu les Yvelinois
conservent leurs septième place au
classement et continue tout de même de
viser le haut de tableau et le podium
pour la fin de saison vous savez qu'on
allait jouer une équipe du Blanc-Mesnil
relativement solide comme ça les tomates
d'ailleurs puisque Mathieu c'était
décidé dans les adieux
donc là une équipe là qui a changé tout
à fait de visage depuis les fêtes de
Noël donc c'est une équipe très
compétitive nous voilà on a fait on a
fait notre match j'ai en ce moment au
sein du groupe là ça travaille bien il y
a vraiment une bonne osmose c'est
dommage justement c'est osmose arrive un
peu tardif elle est un peu tardif pardon
dans la saison mais globalement là sur
le match du jour bon voilà ils auraient
nous a manqué que qu'un but chez les
femmes 14e journée de promotion
d'honneur ont suivi évidemment Élancourt
et les élans courtois se sont inclinés
sur le terrain de l'Entente Sportive du
16e de buza 1 Les Amazones conservent
tout de même leur septième place
handball handball féminin plutôt 17e
journée de Nationale 2 Montigny recevait
le leader landylanpole mais les
inimmontaines n'ont pas réussi de
nouvelles exploits et s'incline
logiquement 27 à 22 et reste 5e au
classement chez les moins de 18 ans
huitième journée de la phase finale du
championnat de France et contre
performance de plaisir aux paris Galaxy
club les plaisirs les plaisirs rois
s'inclinent lourdement 37 à 21 et au
classement vous allez le voir avec cette
cinquième défaite de la saison les
joueurs d'Alexandre Taillefer rétrograde
à la cinquième place de leur poule avec
14 points 10 longueurs du leader
cristolien mais à seulement deux petits
points de la troisième place un peu
d'automobile depuis 2009 la marque
Renault a décidé de renforcer son
activité de concept car et voici le
petit dernier le Quid pour la première
fois le constructeur automobile a lancé
un concept car destiné spécifiquement à
un pays étranger en l'occurrence l'Inde
Renault est déjà implanté sur place avec
une usine à chenille qui produit les
puls véhicules adaptés au marché indien
et les Duster très populaires là-bas le
jaune rappelle également les épices côté
innovation technologique un drone est
placé à l'arrière et permet de prendre
des images de la route ou d'un des quais
par exemple d'éventuelles bouchons
pour faire un véhicule pour les jeunes
Indiens on a fait cet objet là donc qui
est dessiné et imaginé un peu comme des
véhicules radiocommandés donc vous avez
des roues qui sort vraiment de la caisse
donc vous avez une carrosserie qui est
très solide donc c'est un faux 4K une
sorte de oroad qui je crois est très
bien adapté sur ce marché là en plus
quand vous vous regardez l'intérieur
donc c'est vraiment inspiré de l'Inde il
y a beaucoup d'objets qui déroulent
là-bas avec des banquettes avant donc
des riches cas donc on a mis ici le
conducteur en centre avec deux passagers
sur le côté donc vraiment une
inspiration de l'air après leur moisson
de 5 médailles au dernier championnat du
monde de cyclisme sur piste à Cali en
Colombie les membres de l'équipe de
France étaient honoré ce vendredi par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines au Vélodrome justement à côté
des célèbres champions
était aussi présent Thomas Bouddha le
tout jeune champion du monde de l'Omnium
à 20 ans le Bordelais a créé la
sensation avec ce titre seulement pour
sa deuxième saison en équipe de France
élite il a désormais le regard tourné
comme tous ces coéquipiers de l'équipe
de France vers les Jeux olympiques de
Rio en 2016 première médaille au
championnat du monde pour moi grande
satisfaction pour moi et pour toute
l'équipe de France parce que voilà
justement ça met en avant tous les tous
les sacrifices qu'on fait l'équipe de
France la ville de Saint-Quentin avec ce
beau Vélodrome et c'est une façon aussi
de les remercier après 15 jours de
courses nos gazelles yvelinoise sont
rentrés saines et sauve du Maroc
Christelle Lebert et Sophie chevalier
viennent tout juste de retrouver la
France et pour leur première
participation Rallye des Gazelles les
Yvelines une excellente cinquième place
de leur catégorie crossover dans cette
24e édition je vous le rappelle toujours
100% féminine 160 équipages étaient en
course et on parcouru 6 étapes en 8
jours sans aucune connexion web avec
l'extérieur évidemment dans les
prochains 7 8 sport Christelle et Sophie
viendront nous raconter leur expérience
marocaine c'est la fin de ce 7 8 sport
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
la semaine prochaine vous retrouver
Olivier Maniscalco quant à moi je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur TV
film